yeah the big question moving forward and
I really think is how this will work at
various internet speeds but also how are
you going to access these games and with
stadia it is now available at the
highest level of gaming but wouldn't it
be even more magical if that same game
and that same instant experience could
be available across any screen type in
your life well we've known about it for
a while now but Google has finally
really talked about stadia yep their new
cloud streaming service we learned quite
a bit yesterday Wow
I think the craziest thing for me was
probably the fact that they're going to
be integrating so closely with YouTube
to the point where you can watch the
video of a game and hit play and
literally join right where that video
yeah is in that game with no loading or
anything you will notice the play now by
simply clicking on that button the
player is brought directly into the game
in a browser in as quick as five seconds
with no download what else stuck out to
you well that that was one of the things
that stuck out to me is that stadia is
not just here's a cloud-based gaming
platform it's all the other things that
Google can do with integration like the
stuff with YouTube and with Google
assistant now I'm a little skeptical on
that like I don't want no AI voice
listening to me or anything like that
but I hate to break it to you that's
happening already like their their
controller that you can get for
specifically for stadia has a lot of
integrated stuff with their buttons and
with the microphone on top of all their
YouTube integration it's just the way in
which you can share gameplay stuff as
well because you can send like a
timestamp on a clip and then someone can
like essentially join in on that that
part of the game or direct you and you
can contact someone and be like hey I
need help with this section there's just
a lot of things around the edges that
are making this very unique aside from
being a new platform now as a new
platform another thing that stuck out to
me was how much power is behind the
hardware that's running these things in
the data centers yeah so like 10.7
teraflops is that the yeah yeah so this
is going to be more powerful than Xbox
1x if this is Google's plans for the
future then you would sort of expect it
to be better than anything that's out
right now Google has said that they're
gonna do 4k 60fps now that also depends
on
I said 8k yeah okay in the future and I
am thinking about a tres I'm barely even
running 4k right now but yeah that's
that's gonna depend on how the games are
optimized for this stuff because you
can't just like slap on anything and say
it's gonna run 4k 60fps right these are
still games that you can tinker with
settings and all that so it really just
depends on all the games but it is gonna
be capable of that yeah and you know
when we talk about other platforms
obviously the idea of cross-platform
games comes to mind and like where will
it be best like yeah you could think
like right now on paper if everything
Google is offering works as planned well
that will be on stadia but he was also
saying that like yeah like each instance
is ten point whatever teraflops but we
can also turn it up yeah so what I'm
really interested in is like I guess
exclusives that are going to just be for
Google to just kind of follow their
imagination and go wild like yeah I'm
imagining just you know look they
brought in Jade Raymond they're hoping
up a brand new division to both make
games and work with artists to do that
first party studios and work with other
developers like you know for third
parties like there's just there's so
much potential for like an in a new era
of just like where power isn't the thing
that limits game design
yeah it's accessibility right I think
along with all the stuff that we
mentioned previously it's just you know
being able to jump into a game right
like I could buy something on stadia I
imagine and it's like hit play and it's
up in a Chrome browser you're like
that's pretty dope as long as you have a
good internet connection though of
course right that's always the thing
with this it's not local hardware that's
running this stuff it depends on your
internet connection I know there's a lot
of places we've talked about this before
is that there's a lot of places in which
they don't necessarily have the Internet
infrastructure that might be reliable
for this sort of thing to work properly
yeah and you know we tried out project
stream which is just the name for that
limited demo of Assassin's Creed Odyssey
a while back I think in general everyone
thought that felt pretty good but you
played on the show floor like at the
convention we really don't know what
conditions it was played under you would
assume that they had like the best
internet they could get there we're in
San Francisco is a very big Convention
Center it should be great but you said
it wasn't as smooth as it was before
yeah so I would have a caveat
saying like I don't know what the exact
xual conditions are but I did play doom
2016 on the show floor and I don't know
I wasn't too impressed with that because
doom is a game in which he liked that
that game moves fast it's hyper fast and
it's an FPS so you got to be precise you
got to do a lot of you know precision
aiming and I was playing with a keyboard
and mouse and I noticed immediately that
you know my mouse wasn't tracking 100%
perfectly with with the aiming reticle
like it was laggy and in a game like
that like almost immediately and it also
affects the actual gameplay yeah so I
mean that was disappointing but again
I'm not gonna say that this is this is
not final this is an early build up
stadia so and let's be honest to Google
was showing their hand they had a screen
up with the latency of all the inputs
yeah which is I think kind of brave for
them to do when like demos out of their
control right you're the one playing the
game it's gonna happen the way it's
gonna happen so yeah like obviously we
know that there's still a lot of work to
be done in a lot of ways we don't know
how it was played but it just does Allah
straight the sort of like yeah broad
range of experience is you might wind up
in you might be one person who's super
lucky or you might be one that just like
the conditions just don't work right
yeah yeah yeah the big question moving
forward you know I really think is how
this will work at various internet
speeds but also how are you going to
access these games there is no
indication of a subscription service
that's just what people want to believe
right speaking to emo after the event
yesterday he was saying maybe you'll
rent a certain amount of time per week
to play you have you buy your games
outright you know I mean even the way
they monetize games this is going to
change you said the way Ubisoft thinks
about their current practices so do you
think this can survive without a Netflix
style subscription service I think you
can but if that does depends on what the
actual models gonna look like I mean I
can I can see a world in which they give
you multiple options like Guillermo said
with renting time or you can just like
say I have a digital license so just
play the game whenever I want but also
the thing is I always think about like
physical Hardware still or physical
software to like man we see like a lot
of services
like shut down I'm not saying like this
I mean this thing isn't even out yet but
if you're thinking to like the far far
future is like we're not gonna own games
or move into something like stadia
that's just something I'm concerned
about but in terms of like having this
survive for like people buying software
it's you know I imagine Google's got
some clever ways to make this work for
people or have it make sense for people
who buy a lot of games to play a lot of
games so it has to go full circle back
to the developers to right if it doesn't
work they're consumers ultimately it's
not going to feed the developers the
budgets and money they need to take
advantage of what Google is doing yeah
like a huge concern about software
preservation and everyone's talks about
Scott Pilgrim right that ps3 I mean it
got bold and like it's a wonderful game
amazing soundtrack and no one can really
play it like that's one of many examples
we've seen of games that just disappear
for one reason or another because there
is no physical version but it's almost
like it's inevitable like I think we'll
still see 90% of industry will offer
physical options but yeah an exclusive
on Google I keep wanting to say stream
on Google stadia
like what is that yeah yeah just that
would be that we go there and just the
fact that it's software is up on there
is saying like okay do be turtle is
gonna come out on multiple platforms but
they're out here at GDC showing like on
all this is our upcoming game this is
the next doom game running on stadia and
we're gonna show you like new gameplay
of it running on stadia like that I
think that says a lot like albeit my
demo my demo time wasn't all that great
but it says a lot when it's software is
also on board with this saying like
here's an unreleased game on an
unreleased platform I think that's
pretty bold yeah and maybe he's cuz
Google's got the got the name they got
the money we've been do this for years
like yeah you be soft in square enix
apparently I've been working with Google
for six years on this tech figuring out
what it needs to be how they can make it
work for them as a company as creators
and stuff
I mean they've been taking this really
seriously for a long time it's very easy
that it's really just kind of come out
now in the way that it has like we've
hadn't known about rumors and stuff but
the funniest rumor of which was I think
the controller knock up leading up to
the event oh yeah people are so quick to
look at things like you know fake fan
renders and get really upset
we still haven't really tried the
controller just keep playing it you were
not on the bet thing we don't know how
that really feels yeah I mean look it
looks perfectly fine it was only
showcased in like a plastic or a glass
case I didn't get hands-on with it
because it wasn't I guess it's not ready
but yeah I don't know I was using
keyboard and mouse controls this thing
will work with ps4 Xbox one controllers
other third-party controllers so there's
a lot of options and you kind of expect
that from Google is that they think of
every possible case and take care of it
and if they can't take care of it they
will let you know with stadia we can all
dream bigger and together build a
playground for every imagination all
right so where are you on the I would
probably see this is this is bad this is
okay this is like very good this could
be unsure you know yeah yeah because I'm
impressed by the actual technology and
all the things they're doing around the
edges I'm still thinking about my demo
time and all that but you know I've we
did product stream I've tried playing
other games on cloud services and those
have been great so you know we know it
can work and be good yeah we know this
style of game can work and if someone
can pull it off it's probably going to
be Google
[Music]
[Applause]